that's how you sit that's what we call
people yellow you call the BLT
well you said what I'm jeanna cuz you
said white so it's not color was the
right way to do it right no when you
what should I say I'm sorry when you go
take a test
is there a yellow box there's a white
box well white is okay but not yellow or
brown that maybe y'all are the ones that
created these tests I didn't create any
test for you talking about if you watch
this series and have seen the most
recent one with Kendall you know change
my mind usually results in a nice civil
discussion where we find common ground
and people learn a few new things
unfortunately there's always that one
guy or gal or Z who's looking to play
the same old accusation just walk up to
you and called you a racist yes but
let's take it from the beginning
let me share be going up and see what's
going on
let's see let's move at least one camera
Hey
hi hi you guys like to come which boy in
the Hat this guy in the white house
walked up to you and called you a racist
yes okay I'm sorry I have no idea what's
going on so dude were you there I was
did Garrett welcome and call me racist
you said you walked up and call them a
racist I said that sound you want to
hear NSN I said that sounds a bit racist
because you said everybody over here is
a lot of what see a lot of white people
people are white by the way he's black
did you know that's not racist gentlemen
is going up back okay the people who are
organizing this event or white okay
is that racist well just odd that you
would stated no it's off because I said
I would love to know you know how many
people are actually on both sides of the
spectrum
sure Republicans and Democrats over here
oh so you don't want a nice because
that's gonna go shopping at weakest
attire three minutes in real fast and
then he came over white guy and a brown
or yellow guy I'm Mexican Brown wrong
guy people yellow you call the VLE well
you said what I'm Jenna because you said
white so I thought caller was the right
way to do it right no when you what
should I say I'm sorry when you go take
a test
is there a yellow box there's a white
board so white is okay but not yellow
around that I mean y'all are the ones
that created these tests I didn't create
any tests for you talking about I want
to make sure that I see a lot of around
people here yes that oh is that okay for
me to say it's not okay to say oh you're
just a yellow person I didn't say you're
just a yellow person okay I said one
white guy to a yellow or brown
one white got let's sit down have a good
conversation one white guide to a yellow
or brown you know the nice boy racist my
point is I was pointing out the fact
that there are a lot of people over here
that organizing this event that are
white that is he's back he's Okinawan
the man who spoke with you was black I
asked him I have two little the knowing
he's Colombian drug that man's black
you're a racist I also thank you very
much I have to when I purchase a gun I
have to check Caucasian as well as not
Latino which kind of seems racist to me
I mean you just have an agenda over here
just proves both the Victorian American
things about your deniers your skeptics
I mean
you allow no way it in Fox News to tell
you what to believe it it's actually
using your own brain alright then stay
tuned for the next installment a
full-length changed my mind where I
continue to discuss the idea that the
United States is not a racist nation I
believe it and I make no apologies for
it see them hey if you enjoyed this
video subscribe or hit the notification
bell and hit all notifications because
not all notifications work now if you
just hit the normal notification Bell I
think there's some videos playing in
boxes but of course do you consider
subscribing at a lot of credit com / mug
Club because it's a bunch of content
that could never make it onto YouTube
and I think the the box is playing
there's a video playing in a box with